I came out when she kept insisting that
my friend was my best friend to this day
um Adriana was so pretty she's like
she's really pretty she is really pretty
yeah uh unbeknownst to my mother Adriana
is queer lesbian and I was like yeah
she's really beautiful and she's like
she has no boyfriend I was like no I
don't think so I don't think she's no my
mom always knew but she never officially
had an answer or a a sentence or a quote
for me to to validate what her hunts or
her you know
uh and so it was weird because I knew
she knew I think I was always free in my
being that like I thought she knew
because I was always accused of it by
others was that hard it was hard because
she always would have to put up with
that like you know one of my my
um traumatic memories of knowing that I
was different because I was in Mexico
with my Tonka truck which I like playing
with Tonka trucks very manly very boy
yeah but also had dolls and so he had
dolls and he had Tonka trucks and then
people are like what's going on here you
know